E
CONSEQUENCES FOR THESE BIG MEDIA
TECH GIANTS, BUT HOW AND WHEN?
HERE TO EXPLAIN, FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF, FORMER NORTH CAROLINA
CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS ALONG
WITH FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR NICK
GINGRICH.
HE SAID SOMETHING WHEN RUSH
LIMBAUGH PASSED AWAY, YOU HAD
SAID IT BEFORE BUT I HEARD IT
LOUDLY AND CLEARLY DID I
HAPPENED TO BE YOUR AND SEE THAT
NIGHT IN GEORGIA, THE NIGHT YOU
BECAME SPEAKER, I WAS HONORED TO
BE THERE, A NIGHT AND WILL NEVER
FORGET.
HE SAID, YOU DON'T THINK
REPUBLICANS COULD'VE WON BACK IN
94 WITHOUT RUSH.
I'M ASKING THIS QUESTION FOR A
REASON.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK HE CREATED A NATIONAL
AUDIENCE, COULD COMEDIAN SELL
COMMUNIQUE EVERY DAY FOR FREE, E
EDUCATED 30 OR 40% OF THE COUNTN
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
IT TO IMAGINE THAT PERIOD
WITHOUT HIM, IT MAKES IT VASTLY
HARDER FOR US TO HAVE GOTTEN OUR
MESSAGES ACROSS.
>> Sean: I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT, I WOULD SAY WE'VE GOT
TO BECOME THE MEDIA.
OKAY, CONSERVATIVES HAVE TALK
RADIO, THEY HAVE AN OUTLET WHERE
PEOPLE CAN FIND DIFFERENT POINTS
OF VIEW.
A FEW OF US HERE ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL, CERTAINLY NOT
ANYBODY BY ANY STRETCH.
IT WE ARE CONSERVATIVE, I'M
OUTSPOKEN.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE PRESS, SO I
ALSO GIVE OPINION, I'M A TALK
SHOW HOST.
MY QUESTION IS, IS IN NO
CONSERVATIVE'S, PEOPLE IN THE
RIGHT, STOP WHINING AND TO START
CREATING THEIR ALTERNATIVE TO
TWITTER, FACEBOOK, INSTAGRAM,
AND ALL THESE OTHER BIG TECH
GIANTS?
>> WELL, IT IS TIME -- THE
PROBLEM IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO COMPETE.
THEY'VE CREATED THIS DEFECTIVE
MONOPOLY, MY COMMENTS YESTERDAY
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE BREAK
UP BIG TECH IS HARD FOR ME
PHILOSOPHICALLY.
WHAT WE'VE ESSENTIALLY ALLOWED
PLATFORMS TO BECOME IS, THEY ARE
NO LONGER PLATFORMS, THEY ARE
POLITICAL OPERATIONS.
WHEN YOU SEE THAT, WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE NOT ONLY HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE, BUT THAT WE
ALLOW THE FREE MARKET TO
COMPETE.
IT'S MUCH EASIER TO COMPETE WITH
A TWITTER AND RECREATE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD COMPETE HEAD-TO-HEAD
WITH TWITTER.
FACEBOOK, MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
YET, WHAT WE SEE IS THEM
SILENCING ONE OF OUR WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS PROFESSIONALS
THAT WENT TO WORK WITH ELISE
STEFANIK.
IT THEY SAID HIS MISTAKE, WHY
ARE ALL OF THE MISTAKES OF THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE OF THE EYELESS
WHAT WHAT I WANT TO KNOW?
>> Sean: DO WE BREAK UP
MONOPOLIES, OR IS IT A
COMBINATION OF BREAKING UP
MONOPOLIES.
YOU ARE A BIG FUTURE SHOCK FAN,
I'VE LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS
FROM YOU OVER THE YEARS.
OR IS IT TIME TO SAY, OKAY,
WHILE WE ARE PURSUING THAT
OPTION, LET'S CREATE THE
PLATFORMS OURSELVES.
THEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
CHOOSE WHERE THEY WANT TO GO.
>> LOOK, I THINK THERE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS.
FIRST OF ALL, THESE ARE
MONOPOLIES THAT HAVE ENORMOUS
POWER, AND NEVER IN AMERICAN
HISTORY HAVE WE ALLOWED AMERICAN
POWER AND POLITICAL POWER TO
BELONG TO THE SAME PEOPLE.
EVERY TIME THAT'S TRIED TO
HAPPEN, WE'VE HAD A POPULIST
REBELLION CHANGE THE LAWS AND
BROKEN THEM UP.
I WOULD SAY, THE EASIEST
SOLUTION IS TO MAKE THE PUBLIC
CARRIERS WHO ARE LIABLE TO
LAWSUIT -- FOR EXAMPLE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD SUE THEM
FOR THE TOTAL ECONOMIC COST OF
WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO HIM OVER
THE LAST SIX MONTHS.
OR "THE NEW YORK POST" COULD SUE
FOR THE DAMAGES DONE DURING THE
PRAYER JUST BEFORE THE ELECTION
WHEN THEY BANNED THE POST.
HE WOULD SUDDENLY BE FINE THEN
BEHAVING LIKE ECONOMIC ENTITIES.
THAT WOULD BRING YOUR BALANCE.
A SECOND, I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE
THAT CONSERVATIVES SHOULD CREATE
AS MANY ALTERNATIVE MESSAGING
SYSTEMS -- A NIGHT REALLY GETS
YOU INVOLVED WITH GOOGLE.
WITH THE APPLE CLOUD OPERATION,
MORE THAN WITH FACEBOOK OR WITH
TWITTER.
YOU CANNOT AFFORD TO HAVE GOOGLE
DECIDE TO TAKE PEOPLE OFF OR TO
HAVE APPLE DECIDE, AS THEY DID
WITH ONE COMPETITOR, THAT THEY
JUST CLOSE THEM DOWN.
IT THIS IS A KIND OF USE OF
POWER WHICH REALLY DESTROYS ANY
KIND OF FREE ENTERPRISE SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT ELIMINATES THE FREE
ENTERPRISE AND TURNS IT INTO THE
PLAYGROUND OF BILLIONAIRES, WHO
THEN USE THEIR POWER IN WAYS
THAT ARE IMPOSSIBLE IN A FREE
SOCIETY FOR US TO PUT UP WITH.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE -- WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
START TO SEE OUR ACTIONS BY
ATTORNEY GENERALS IN THE STATES.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE ACTIONS BY
GOVERNORS -- GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
IS ALREADY STARTING TO TAKE SOME
INITIATIVES.
LISTEN, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
NOT GOING TO TAKE THIS LYING
DOWN.
I CAN TELL YOU, I TALKED TO
HOUSE AND SENATORS YESTERDAY IN
LIGHT OF THE FACEBOOK DECISION.
AT THIS REAL TAKEN PLACE.
WE ALSO, AS THE SPEAKER IS
TALKING ABOUT, WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THOSE ALTERNATIVE
PLATFORMS, ENCOURAGE
CONSERVATIVES TO GO THERE -- THE
PRESIDENT HAD OVER 200 MILLION
PEOPLE FOLLOWING HIM ON VARIOUS
PLATFORMS, IT'S AN ECONOMIC
ENGINE SITTING THERE WAITING TO